في ملف الطاقه يدخل اعتبارا من اليوم حي
الزعه تنفيذ قرار دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
حضروا واردات النفط الخام الروسي
باستثناءات محدوده
سقف السعر النفط الروسي المنقوري بحرا
بستينا دولارا لكل برميل
ذلك بالحرمان من الخدمات الاساسيه التي
تقدمها دول الاتحاد مثل لها تمويل وتامين
والمساعده الفنيه
دولار فقط لكن خطر صاحبي روسيا نفضاها
الخام بالكامل من اسواق العالميه جعلت
الدول الاوروبيه
تتحاشى هذا الخيار وتتمسك بالسعر الذي
وضعته مجموعه السبعه واستراليا من قبل
خوفا من ارتفاع الاسعار بشكل حاد
وبمازات القرار الاوروبي من المتوقع ان
تقر المملكه المتحده تشريعا مماثلا يدخل
هو الاخر حيث تنفيذ اعتبارا من اليوم تمنع
بموجبه الدول من الاستفاده من خدمات
المملكه المتحده في تسهيل النقل البحري
للنفصل الروسيه الخام ما لم يتم شراؤه وفق
سقف السعر الذي حددته دول مجموعه السبع
واستراليا
العمل في سياستها الحاليه في انتاج النفطه
تشرين الاول الماضي والقاضي بخفض الانتاج
بين ليونيل برميل يوميا حتى نهايه العام
2030 بحره
لدول مثل الصين والهند اتيني رفض سائده
الحرب في اوكرانيا
تبع هذه التطورات مع مراسلنا من برلين
عصام طيبي ومن موسك امين درهامي اهلا بكم
ابدا معك عصام الاوروبيون ما هي حساباتهم
في التعامل مع هذه الاجراءات التي تلوح
بها موسكو والمرتبطه بخفض الانتاج واحداث
اضطراب في سوق الطاقه
باكبر خطوه تاريخيه في تاريخ النفط القديم
وهي خطوه حاسمه لانها ستفرض بحسب الغربيين
فهيمن غربيه على كل النفط وهو ما يعادل
ثلث النفط الروسي المصدر بحرا بمعنى اخر
بان الغربه بامكانه ان يلجا الى كل
البلدان الاخرى غير الاوروبيه بوضع السقف
لهذا النفط الروسي من خلال الاجراءات التي
اتخذها بخصوص فرض شروط لتامين همم
الناقلات البحريه للنفط الروسي من خلال
وضع شروط على المستهلكين غير الاوروبيين
بقبول هذا السعر بمعنى اخر الوصول الى
التحكم في حنفيه صحه تعبير همم تدفق الغاز
والنفط وغيرها من الادوات الخاميه
الاحفوريه الرو الى العالم عن طريق الغرب
الذي يريد من هذه الخطوه ان تكون اعظم
الخطوه له منذ بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا
وباعتباره انها الرساله التي يفهمها
الكريم لتحديدا وهي لعبه النفط كما قال
الغربيون في قرار في بني قرار سريان هذا
هذا هذا هذا الاتفاق الذي طبعا شهيد
جداريا كبيره بين الاطراف الاوروبيه
تحديدا خصوصا تلك دول الاطراف يتحدث عن
المجر مثلا وغير يعني من الدول التي كانت
تحاول تمرد على هذا القرار او تحاول ان
تضع بديلا له بخصوص ان اا احتياجاتها من
النفط والاحفور الروسي كبيره جدا كبيره
جدا وليس لديها استقلال لكن الان
الاوروبيون ودول الغرب عموما تتصدرهم طبعا
المانيا باريس لندن واشنطن في هذا الامر
يريدنا رهف رفع السقف التحدي من خلال وضع
هذا التثقيف السعري للخام الروسي نعم